24 hours ago we were wondering if the
military movement might be restricted to
the donbass but now with that we know
that mr putin is going for broke
he's invading the whole country in a
multi-pronged attack it started in the
donbash region to the east but from kiev
in the north la viv in the west to
odessa in the south there's now been
over 200 attacks taking place since the
start of the day according to the
ukrainian national police service
so let's look at khaki first the most
vulnerable of the big cities in ukraine
near the russian border with lots of
russian speakers it's not surprising
perhaps that russian forces are about to
surround this city
so far russian military attacks look as
if they're only against the ukrainian
military and they're probably hoping
that they'll be able to walk into
undamaged cities that won't try to
defend themselves when they do
we've seen footage appearing to show the
aftermath of an attack on an airbase in
shaheed near kharkiv
sky news has gone through an extensive
verification process to corroborate this
video you'll see two impacts that's to
be expected as missile attacks almost
always involve sending two missiles to
each target that's in order to achieve
something close to a 95 chance of
success we can see the before and after
with these latest satellite images
released by communication services
monitoring the situation the first image
taken on monday and in this one from
today where you can see clearly the
aftermath of the attack now to the west
and what should be the safest city in
ukraine lev
far to the west not part of an
industrial area and close to the polish
border
well it may soon find itself hosting an
unknown number of refugees
80 miles south we've seen video of
another missile hitting an air base
there here the ukrainian air base in
ivano francoise 83 miles south of la vie
it was hit by what looks to be a cruise
missile and in the southwest of ukraine
is odessa a historic city subject to a
missile attack where at least 18 people
have been killed
it's a significant port complex
important for russian forces to control
it if they're trying to take the whole
country
in fact a turkish ship on route from
odessa to romania was hit by a bomb on
thursday afternoon in addition ukrainian
authorities say that parts of the
kirshan region along the crimea's coast
northern coast are no longer under their
control so the big question now is what
happens in kiev home to nearly three
million people
we've heard reports of a number of
attacks on all sides two power plants
one in the south of the city and
chernobyl to the north as well as a
military base in neighbouring gossamell
all examples of being hit by russian
forces trying to paralyze the
infrastructure
russia's attack is engaged in a
multi-prong defensive now there's a
certain degree of risk in this given the
distribution of the forces that the
russians have put into the field
if mr putin is going to succeed in the
way he seems to expect
then he'll probably have to do it
quickly